cool all right thank you all for coming
today I'm going to talk about getting
started with Kosmos DB especially within
the context of EF core so who here has
used cosmos DB before no couple cool
ante framework or some 90% of the room
that's pretty good
all right my name is Thiago pastas I'm a
solution architect working for myself in
Brisbane Australia it was a very long
fight to get here I've been doing
consulting consultant work for over I
don't know 15 years now I've been
sharing a bunch of stuff that I've been
doing we view G as angular a bunch of
edgy stuff in my blog if you know have a
look the whole code that I'm gonna show
today here is in my github as well and
my Twitter if you don't follow me or get
in touch or anything so let's see about
the agenda so I'm gonna talk about what
is cause with ZB and I'm gonna try to
convince you to start using it I'm gonna
show you how to get started I'm gonna
share a few of the tooling that I use
both for development and for some
migration and then I'm gonna add EF call
to that mix all right I'm gonna show you
how to implement how to use Kosmos EB
with aunty framework alright first what
is causes the be so Kosmos DB is a
multi-modal database service for
managing data at a planet scale and it's
also called no sequel right from this
sentence here everything looks alright
okay
no sequel is well known managed service
that's managed and scale looks alright
but when when it comes to multi model
it's kind of funny how a database can be
multi modal and this is because they
have a cosmology we have a bunch of
available api's and this means that
and Eastern South Kosmos DB can be used
with all these api's so you don't need
to learn from scratch how to talk to the
data right so if you're familiar with
sequel you're gonna be fine
using the the sequel if you're familiar
with or gramley or Cassandra or
table storage there is nothing new that
you need to learn that the learning
curve is gonna be quite small
to get started with columns B which is
pretty good so think about cosmos DB as
a big umbrella right so we have all
these database types which are all those
api's will feed into one of those
database types but all of them will have
all these nice features which is the
distribution the distribution the
elastic scale out they guaranteed low
latency and availability and all that
also the the consistency levels which
we're gonna cover a little bit and they
and azure has these awesome
comprehensive SLA which is this contract
from Microsoft and and their customers
which they guarantee 99.99 percent of
availability latency you know that which
is pretty interesting let's talk about
the global distribution and how easy it
is to to scale that like to to add more
read regions okay I come from Australia
so I created the instance in Australia
East so you can see that the right
region is Australia East and now what
I'm gonna do is I want to scale my
application so my vacations going to be
used in Asia it's gonna be using in
Europe in the US and Brazil where I'm
from and that's how easy it is so with a
few clicks you have the data is sync
with multiple regions across the globe
that's that's how simply so you don't
need to be an expert in infrastructure
you don't need to to do any of that and
for us developers at least for me I'm
not an IT specialist I'm not a
infrastructure especially so for me
creating all that
sink is it would be pretty hard and back
in the day doing that with Cinco it will
be a nightmare
all right consistency levels so what
does that mean what's all about
consistency levels so there are five
consistency levels and it's like it's
got its like a scale right so as you go
stronger a strong consistency you're
gonna get you're gonna pay more right so
I'm gonna talk about the five
consistency levels then I'm gonna show
you now there and in a very visual way
so you can understand what they are so
we've got the strong consistency so
think about the first line the first
music shark as being the the right
region okay so as you write data all the
the read regions across all your cluster
they will be in sync and that's gonna be
straight away so that's gonna be the
most expensive consistency level that
you're gonna get right then you have the
ballad sailors so the reader right will
have a strong consistency but as you go
to other regions you're gonna have a
slight leg which is five seconds or
hundred versions whichever is smaller
all right and that's that's acceptable
for most of the applications we write
okay then you have the session and the
session is the the default one and the
most popular one where you have the
regions in a session and every region in
that session you have that strong
consistency for the regions outside that
session we're gonna have a small delay
and that that delay is gonna be bigger
than then the other consistency level
which is bounded our sailors Brazil is
not a big deal it's not that huge then
we have the consistent prefix well
you're gonna see that the consistency
level is is dropping in and at some
point you're gonna think why would I use
that at all all right so the as we write
here you can you can see that the other
regions they read
they are getting the diary in the same
order and for these one it's important
that the data is in the same order so
you have a slight delay for every Ridge
regions but they still in order an
income to the eventual consistency I
guess a lot of people have heard about
that and for me when I saw that the
first time I thought why the heck would
I even use that so you write data and
you might get the data in whichever
order it comes it's like completely
random why would I use that it actually
applies to a lot of cases right for
example for social media when you have
tweets or followers or likes it doesn't
matter if you have 10 here 10 likes here
and 9 in Australia and eventually every
everything every region is going to be
in sync so it doesn't really matter that
that count is different in in different
regions for a slight delay okay and
that's what it means okay so what about
the comprehensive SLA
so it's a contract between Microsoft and
the customers of course and they ensure
that they're gonna give you 99% 99.99
percent of availability throughput
consistency in latency if they don't
provide that it's in their contract if
it's lower than 99.99 percent they're
gonna give you 10% off credit back if
it's lower than 99% they can give you
25% back which is pretty amazing so for
a company to do that well they need to
to have the whole infrastructure to back
them up otherwise they will lose money
so again why would you use cosmos II
being the first place well all that they
recovered so you have the global
scalable with one-click which is amazing
it's fully managed so its surplus it's
it's it's got all these guarantees of
low latency reliability availability and
all that and for developer I think the
most important thing here is that you
have these multiple api's where you
don't have that learning curve is almost
no it's it's almost almost non-existent
because you can use that same API that
he used and how do I get started how to
get started with Kosmos EB it's pretty
simple so you can go to Azure now you
can click on that post button you can
look for calls new CB and then you can
create the recess all right you're gonna
select your API from here just if I
haven't told you at this point here the
API is selected on the creation time so
it's not something that you can change
the API
after you create instance it's selected
when you create instance ok then you get
started so you can click on that
QuickStart and then you can choose your
platform I'll be using dotnet go for 4
years now since it was in beta 4 in
production so I mean I'd be crazy and
from here you can create the items
collection which items items in cosmo ZB
is like a table in sequel right and for
me this example this quick start from
all the products that I've used in the
past that was the in snappiest the
better the best Quick Start that I've
ever seen and I'm gonna show you how I'm
gonna show you why that's that's the
case so you can create one when you're
going to create the items collection and
then you can download a copy of that
QuickStart code right in for the
products around you would download your
code and then you would put some keys
and then you would be connected to your
instance right now with this one so you
can download that and what's gonna
happen is you're just gonna press a5 and
off you go you're connected to your
oysters and for me that was amazing that
was mind-blowing so I'm gonna do a quick
demo here so I've got an instance in
Asia
already and what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to create that instead that items
collection and I'm going to download
that app alright so you can see that
happening
in real life all right so I'm gonna
download that and zip who here uses
writer not just a few it's amazing
should use this alright so I'm gonna
open my solution with writer alright so
what's gonna happen here it's gonna load
the project it's gonna restore the
dependencies and I'm just gonna press f5
and open the application just just see
how it how it works all right
Gate sinking restoring
all right it's all good I'm going to
press a five and I'm gonna run the
application
so the application should open in the
browser now it's this is an MVC with
dotnet core application that's a very
simple application and as usual it's
just that should do okay so we're gonna
open that now and in the meantime what
I'm gonna do just just wait that to
finish okay so what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna go to back to Asia so I can open
the data Explorer in there
okay I'm gonna open that in full screen
just so we can see that when we run the
application when we create data that's
showing you up in our instance okay so
you can see that we have the collection
that was created when I press the button
and I have no documents at this point in
time okay
so I can go to my to-do list here my
to-do app and I'm gonna create a few
children's so I'm gonna buy some milk on
my on my way home
create a few more here so I'm gonna have
breakfast with my mate Jason Oh in fact
I already had I have to change it later
and I'm gonna let's say bring juice for
some reason we see for Brandon to to
drink
all right so just one last one that I'm
gonna create just so we can have enough
data to play with in cozy B and I'm
gonna drink more water in the morning as
I said I had a breakfast with Jason
already so I'm just gonna edit that so I
can't set that you complete it alright
so now I have four items one of them is
completed okay so I'm gonna go to
Coleman's DB now I'm gonna refresh and
you're gonna see that we have all
documents in eating sense that I just
created
okay all right so the only difference
there is that this complete is true and
I'm gonna create a new a new query so
these looks like sequel right select
star from C and what's DC with with
cozzens DB when you run a when you run a
sequel query the context of that query
is the collection it's not like sequel
that's the whole database it's within
that collection so if you want to do
joins and things like that there's gonna
be within within the collection okay and
there are reasons for that and this is
because it's a document database under
the covers and essentially used to all
that in in a single everything that you
need in a single document so let's run
that and see what it comes back so
hopefully gonna come back with the full
records that I created okay so let's run
and there you go we've got the full
records that I created
okay so let's see how the syntax works
here so I'm gonna do a where C dot this
complete or complete equals true
okay so if I run that I should get a
single one okay so that's no sequel so
it can be different so I can basically
remove that equals true because it's
gonna work the same way with sequel that
wouldn't work and also I can do an odd
is complete and that would work as well
what does go here so let's try something
else
so let's try a name like beer so that's
a valid sequel statement isn't it so
that's right out see if we run that now
I get an error so that's not valid so
there are some differences with this
transact sequel so in this case I should
use contains and then the name the field
and what I want to check inside so I can
run that all right there is no beer in
my documents just juice all right so let
me that's that's an error there should
be beers inside there that's that's not
right so I'm gonna try it I'm gonna I'm
gonna check what's inside so there is
milk this is breakfast juice yeah there
is juice is water I'm gonna try water
all right what's that so I'm gonna try
water so they should they should bring
something back now cool so I've got
something all right but I still think
that that's a bug all right I still
think it's a bug
all right so I'm gonna just get the
fields that want now I'm gonna get the
ID the name and it's complete because I
don't want all that let's stuff coming
back all right so that's the same way
that sequel works
all right so cosmos DB has a bunch of
features as well so cosmos DB has also
store procedures triggers and user
defined functions so it's like it's like
sequel but the way they behave is a bit
different so you can see that on the top
there we have new stop see you so we can
create that
and it's basically a JavaScript function
which is pretty amazing
right so you don't need to know sequel
at all you can just write a JavaScript
function there any it's gonna work so
I'm gonna create a new user defined
function and I'm gonna fix that bug I'm
gonna create a BFI function I'm gonna
get that value and I'm gonna do a
replacement here I'm gonna return the
value replace I'm gonna write some
regular expression here I'm gonna
replace by doea all right so that was a
bug and I'm I'm keen to fix that bug so
I'm gonna create a regular expression
and what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
replace globally and I'm gonna get let's
see juice I'm gonna replace juice what a
breakfast and milk so I'm gonna replace
old that by beer because I need to fix
that bug all right so now the way we can
use that we can use that in the query or
in the field itself so what I'm gonna do
is UDF BFI lame and I'm also gonna put
an alias for that as name and I'm gonna
run that so you can see the bugs fixed
now I need to buy beer I need to have
beer with my mate Jason and what else I
need to bring beer for Brendan because
he doesn't lean it doesn't drink juice
and I need to drink more beer in the
morning I guess I don't know if my leave
is gonna handle all that let's see
alright so now what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna go back to that project so you see
that the QuickStart project is working
fine so I just press f5 and everything
is linked up which is pretty good but
before that we also have triggers and
these triggers you can assign to an
operation right to any operation when
you create when you delete when you
replace some documents and you can also
trigger that either
for updating or after which is pretty
good but let's go now to the project
okay just a little bit all right so what
I'm gonna show you here is how that
project works so it's it's a simple MVC
application so we've got that item
controller which is just to create
delete update items and we've got this
document DB repository in here let me
great alright so it's got this great AC
which is the one that we used so it's
gonna receive an item and it's gonna use
that repository to to create an item so
let's see the implementation of that and
that's all the sample code which is
which is pretty good and then we have
all that that key and the endpoint
already in the code I agree that there's
not best practice to put the disk keys
in the code it should be not acting
seagull or web.config or something like
that but where it's working so you know
exactly where to change if you want to
apply to different to different
collection or different database and
what I'm going to show you here is the
the NuGet package that use to connect to
causes the B so that's not using AF core
so that's just using the default library
which is the document to be alright so
with that document DB in place we can
create that client document DB with that
endpoint and the key that you saw just
above and I'm going to use that client
in a few places
it's a simple all right so let's talk
about the toolings and that's something
that I learned the hard way so in last
year I went to NDC Sydney as well and I
presented a talk about logic apps just
pretty cool logic apps is pretty
interesting and what I did was I was
gathering a bunch of tweets with ended
conference and I was running through a
bunch of cognitive services just to see
the level of happiness and all that and
I was pushing all that you causes the be
instance okay and after the conference
was gone I had all this data in my
cousin's DB instance and I didn't know
what to do with this data and I didn't
have time to think about what to do with
the data so I left there for a while so
I was being like 100 bucks a month just
for the instance well I'm not a company
a hundred bucks a month for nothing it's
quite a lot I can drink a lot of coffee
with a hundred bucks a month but it was
there and I didn't know what to do and
it was there you know I was paying that
money every month so eventually I found
out about this tool these data migration
to which which I should have searched
before right this was this tools pretty
cool so what it does is it's almost like
that sequel to to get data from one
place and push to the other which is
pretty interesting and that's how it
works so I'm just gonna open that that
same instance that I had and I'm gonna
show you how to extract extract that
data that we just added
you just put somewhere else okay so I'm
gonna open now I've got that tool
available second
okay so I've got a tool available here
I'm gonna open it up I'm gonna go to
source information and I'm gonna select
document DB so you see that I can have
multiple source types I'm gonna need
this the connection string so I'm gonna
go to keys here you know Joe I'm going
to copy that connection string also I'm
gonna open that X colleges to make sure
the database name in the collection name
is there so I'm gonna set a database
name here to children list in the
collection true items and I'm gonna set
a query so this query could be any any
query any valid query and I'm gonna save
that your local JSON file just so I can
extract all the data that's currently in
call whose DB so I can have that so
that's what I did in the past okay so
I'm gonna press next don't I don't care
about the logs and I'm gonna import that
Watson I'm gonna close that up
and I'm gonna open that file that see my
desktop so I'm just gonna format tab and
there you go that's how simple it is to
expect the Dharam right I should have
known that before I spend a hundred
bucks a month for a while cool there is
also a tool called cosmos DB emulator
and if you are planning to do any
development using columns to be that's a
must a must for you right so you need to
store that locally so you don't need to
spin up any instance in a just so you
can work completely offline completely
locally with that which is which is
pretty cool so let's see how that works
so I'm gonna run at them with that as
well okay so I'm gonna start here the
cosmos TV emulator I should have done
that before
hopefully they compete like a crush on
me okay so starting the emulator and as
soon as it started it's gonna open the
browser with that instance that local
instance running so you can see that at
the top I've got localhost 8080 one and
you can see and it's like Asia but it's
running locally just for cousin ZB so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna get at
that primary connection string and I'm
gonna update my application that should
do a plication so you can see that there
is no database I'm gonna update that to
do database that should do a plication
to use the local database instead the
local cause DB so I'm gonna paste that
here also the format seems a bit
different so I'm just gonna put the
endpoint up copy that and I'm going to
remove this trash here awesome so let's
run that again
and once I run and once I add items to
my columns DB instance it's gonna go to
my local instance okay which is cool
because now you don't need to pay
anything just to to start working with
the gesture to learn how to use go to be
locally alright so you can see that now
the applications running any credit
automatically they should the list and
items but I have no documents so I'm
gonna go and create a document that's a
local instance I'm going to create
awesome I can see the documents there
and it's running locally alright so
everything else will work the same way
it's pretty good awesome so let's talk
about EF Co and that's gonna be how to
implement how to use the Kosmos IV with
with yeah of course
but I've got a bit of a story to tell
with that when I found out about this
data this cosmos provider for UFO I was
really really excited and that was I
don't know about six months ago so I was
really really excited I even wrote a
blog post about it and I was this
seventy second person she don't know the
package so it was pretty early on but I
was really I was really excited I wanted
to choose a name I managed to so I wrote
a blog post about it so I was pretty
excited and then I found out that I was
coming here I was coming to NDC London
to present about it and as as I used my
put my blog I I create a post so I can
reference back to myself so I can
remember the kind of stuff that I was
doing so if I get stuck again I get back
to my blog to see what I did in the past
so I went there to start preparing for
this talk and I I went you to the to the
code and I tried to run and it wasn't it
wasn't working it was well it was
working before what's going on and then
I saw that the nougat package wasn't
coming off I'm sure that that was coming
before so I went to nougat org and I
couldn't find what's going on there is
there is something pretty bad going on
here so wait you get oh I couldn't find
and eventually I found the link that
went straight to that nougat package in
nougat world and I found that I was oh
that's good
everything gonna work now that's that's
all good but as I was writing then you
get packaged I was reading I saw these
yellow box there and I was about to come
here so I saw the owner has unlisted
this package this could mean that the
package is deprecated or shouldn't be
used anymore I was far out how can I
present on something that it shouldn't
be used I'm so much trouble so I started
freaking out but it eventually I found
out that they actually renamed then you
get back if they just ditched the dot
sequel from the name
and I couldn't breathe again good all
right so let's see how that works so
let's see how that's implemented so I'm
gonna use that local insistent now I'm
not going to use the edges I'm gonna use
the local instance I'm gonna copy the
connection string so I've got a code
sample that I there a road for this talk
and it's available on github if you guys
want to check it out so that's cf cosmos
so I'm gonna open that up in writer of
course
okay so hopes not gonna take long to
load all right so I'm gonna show you
around the application a little bit just
so you can understand I'm just gonna
first update the app settings or chasing
with local instance so I'm gonna paste
it here and I'm gonna replace choose the
endpoint don't don't copy the key men
don't take a photo of the key all right
okay so these application is a simple
application and all I have here is so
you saw the name of the the databases
blog and I'm gonna store here authors
categories and posts okay that's implies
that any post you have a reference to
author and you have a reference to
category okay okay so I've got a single
controller here so I'm using this part
and plate to create this application and
I've got a post controller just to
create a post and to retrieve all the
posts just to test it out okay so let's
see the implementation of that post post
okay so I'm getting a post model here
which is bringing the the name the
author ends off with that
so I'm initiating an entity the post
entity I'm gonna bind the the title the
author subterranean and author when I
bind and up creating a category when I
bind okay so then I use these that the D
becomes the DB context true add that new
entity and I save the changes so breathe
vanilla stuff right anything different
than you guys usually do okay
all right
so let's have a look at the persistence
in our depositions so the DB contact
that big context looks exactly the same
as any DB context right so I've got a
bunch of DB sets for post categories and
author but there is nothing new there is
nothing different in the DB context so
it's using EF core here and there is no
difference and the only difference here
is gonna be in this startup so if for
you if I was using sequel what I would
do here is when adding the context I
would use use sequel right but in the
case of Cosmos to be I'm gonna use cos
Ruby and I'm gonna add that add entity
framework cosmos which comes from that
package and that's pretty much it
so there is nothing more to it but we
can see how it's done behave okay so I'm
going to run out a little bit all right
so I'm gonna run the application
[Applause]
you know I gotta go to the application
pretty simple I'm gonna list the posts
and I'm gonna go to my local instance
and I'm going to see that I have a blog
database in a blog to be context
collection well I didn't like that in
the first place
it didn't feel right I was expecting to
see both authors and categories right
but instead I got this blog to be
context well that's fine so I'm going to
create a blog just so we can see how
that behaves so getting started with
Kosmos to be the carrier dynamic cosmos
and the author is Thiago passes in the
contents awesome I'm gonna create that
so the posts gonna come back here
eventually
there you go and I'm gonna go to my
emulator and I'm gonna refresh that all
right so now I have three documents
coming up and I didn't understand it in
the first place it didn't make any sense
so I went there and I said and I checked
that it was opposed so the content is
awesome
the the tyro is getting started with
Kosmos it'd be its colonies
discriminator got a post
discriminator and it's got this author
ID in category ID so as i went to the
next document i saw that each document
is related to a different entity okay
and then i I started thinking that that
was actually a pretty compliment a ssin
so it's use polymorphism out of the box
and you didn't you don't need to
configure anything so it's all in the
same bucket which later when I found out
that I learned that was actually a
pretty quite year because the
collections in Cosmo CB they is scale
separately so you can create collections
to scale differently okay but I didn't
like that so I didn't like the fact that
the name was the name of the DB context
so I want
do up to update that so I'm gonna update
it becomes context here so I'm going to
get that morale builder and get the
infrastructure and I'm gonna override
the convention of course with a B and
I'm going to set the default container
name to default instead of having blog
to be context okay so if I write that
now if I run this now what am I
expecting to see is did the default
collection coming out in my database
okay so I'm gonna run that okay all
right let me open that here so I'm gonna
refresh obviously no posters when I come
back because now it's reading from the
default collection and if i refresh my
instance here my local instance you're
gonna see that I have a default
collection now instead of that blog to
be context so I'm not write a post just
to try it out and everything now should
go to that default context the default
collection is there okay so the post
should come back awesome and now I have
the three documents coming in the
default collection alright so for me
that was a win because now I have more
control over the convention alright so I
really didn't like having the name of
the collection with the name of the
dbcontext alright but I still don't like
the fact that posts and categories and
authors in the same bucket so I want to
separate that so let's see how we can
separate I'm just going to stop here I'm
going to use that model buta again but
now I'm gonna get that entity and I'm
gonna override metadata of that entity
and I'm gonna set the container name for
that specific entity okay so what I'm
expecting to see now is when I create a
post that's gonna go to the post
collection
everything else should go to the default
collection all right so I'm gonna
refresh here it should bring back one
post okay
oh not cuz I create a post sorry you
shouldn't bring any post because there
isn't there is no post there so I'm
gonna create a post now
okay and you know if I go back to my
emulator any fresh I should have the
post in the post collection right and
everything else the author and the
category will show up in the default
collection right with the background
that I had with sequel I still didn't
like this idea right even though this is
actually something that you should do
because all the older data that's not
the main data it's probably a good idea
to put it in the same bucket because
then you can scale that less than the
main data but what I'm gonna do here is
I'm gonna create a method which I'm
using reflection just to go through the
DB sets of my DB context and I'm just
gonna set all that to set the main the
container name for each of the of the DB
sets alright so I'm gonna call that you
know in a run I should have all the data
sets in separate collections does that
make sense
let's run okay so if I update now the
post should come back with no category
in order because now they're coming to a
different collection but the post is
still coming from posts so should have a
post with no category in water so now if
we refresh here we're gonna have all
these collections coming up authors and
categories
cool so now it's looking like more more
like the way you would program with
sequel right even though it's um it's
not something that you should do you
should put some data that will scale
differently in one bucket so when I add
that now I should have a new post and a
new author in the author collection in a
new category in the category collection
cool all right so as I said I wouldn't I
wouldn't do that for for a real life
application right I would put posts in
its own collection or any main data in
its own collection because then I can
scale that differently so if I have more
users I'm gonna scale that that main
data more so users can get access to
that data way quickly quicker and then
for any auxiliar data I would put that
all the auxiliar data in one bucket so I
can scale that less does that make sense
all right so if you're ready for that
there is a cosmo task list in on github
it's a github issue in the cosmos DB in
the H framework or account and you can
check what's available right now so they
have a lot of stuff available so you can
see that in preview one they build a
bunch of stuff and then if you go ahead
right now they're on preview three three
three point zero three two three and RTM
is coming soon so hopefully it's coming
soon there is no date yeah but you can
see the plan it's long it's almost like
a board
I can't even board for them which is
pretty good so let's let's summarize
here so I know a bit short on time which
will give you more time to drink off
now let's summarize so what is cousins
it be and why
mainly because well it's awesome so you
should should give it a try should you
should try to work with that it's
amazing the Getty started this is so
nice to experience for me it was the
best experience I've had in a long time
the best at five experience in a long
time that I had even for the project's
arrived so I usually don't put any
anything any any details there to just
press a five in work right so that was
pretty nice
and then wiring up with the F Cole I
really like I really like the
implementation they did that they did
it's not fully done yet but well I'll be
using donít course since it was bitter
for four years ago in production so I
had my my headaches but well I got it I
got there so if the feature that you're
looking for already in the cosmos DB
provider just go and use it you're going
to have some headaches but well you're
gonna get in to the end so I shared also
some tooling so the data migration and
the cosmos emulator and that's something
that you should definitely have a look
if you want to start using cosmos a B
and also I shared with with you the task
list so check check the task list see
what's there
see if you're happy with the features
that are available right now and start
using it thank you very much
[Applause]
what sorry questions yeah not yet not
yet
yeah not at this point not that I know
of they can run secret you can write the
sequel and then just run with yeah of
course it's not ideal but you can
anymore
no oh good Thank You Raj